Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the city of Tenochtitlan, the drums were beating. All morning, the streets had been buzzing with excitement. Old and young, rich and poor, men, women and children, everybody had heard the news. After weeks of tension, after all the whispers and rumors, the strangers had entered the valley of Mexico and had reached the far side of the lake. In just a few hours, they would be on the causeway.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入。特诺奇蒂特兰城内，鼓声阵阵。整个上午，街道上都弥漫着兴奋的气息。无论老少、贫富、男女，每个人都听到了这个消息。经过数周的紧张局势，在所有的窃窃私语和传言之后，那些陌生人已经进入了墨西哥谷，并抵达了湖泊的远岸。再过几个小时，他们就会踏上堤道。
And then, at last, the people of the city would set eyes on these extraordinary newcomers from across the sea. Now there was silence. A last hush before the storm. The sun blazed down the tension hung in the air heavier and heavier and then an invisible tremor ran through the spectators on the rooftops a breathless gasp of excitement on the edge of the Aztecs by top historian of Mesoamerica, Dominic Sandbrook. So Dominic, this is the latest volume in your series of books written for
终于，城里的人们将亲眼见到这些来自海那边的非凡来客。此刻，一片寂静。暴风雨前的最后宁静。烈日当空，空气中的紧张感愈发沉重，随后，屋顶上的观众中传过一阵无形的颤栗，那是阿兹特克人边缘地带发出的兴奋喘息。由中美洲顶级历史学家多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）讲述。那么，多米尼克，这是你为孩子们撰写的系列丛书中的最新一卷。
children. And do you know, I think it's the episode in history that I find most fascinating that I kind of don't know much about. Yes. Well, thank you, Tom. Thank you for that wonderful reading. I think you do incredible justice because this is the meeting, isn't it, of old world and new, of Europe and Central America, of Cortez, the Spanish adventurer, and Moctezuma, the great king of the Aztecs. Yes. I should say, Tom, North America, before we get letters of complaint from our many, many Mexican listeners. But yes, thank you. That's very kind of you.
你知道吗，我认为这是历史上最令我着迷，但我却知之甚少的一段。是的。好吧，谢谢你，汤姆。感谢你那精彩的朗读。我认为你做得非常到位，因为这确实是旧世界与新世界、欧洲与中美洲、西班牙冒险家科尔特斯与阿兹特克伟大国王蒙特祖马的会面，不是吗？是的。我应该说，汤姆，是北美，以免收到我们许多墨西哥听众的投诉信。但是的，谢谢你。你太客气了。
This is the moment on the 8th of November, 1519, when Hernan Cortes and the Aztec Emperor Montezuma meet on the causeway outside the great city of Tenochtitlan, now Mexico City. It's one of the mostway outside the great city. It's in Oshetland, now Mexico City. It's one of the most famous meetings in all history. It is an absolutely extraordinary historical moment. I mean, it's the closest Europeans would ever come to meeting aliens, I suppose. And the same, by the way, for the Mesoamericans. This sort of clash of civilizations, the meeting of these two men, there's been so much debated. It's not just the meeting of these two men that has been so much debated. It's not just the meeting of two individuals, but it carries so much baggage now, doesn't it? Because it's a foundational moment in the story of colonialism, of European imperialism, of the Columbian exchange between the great land masses of our planet, the old world and the new,
这是1519年11月8日的时刻，埃尔南·科尔特斯（Hernan Cortes）与阿兹特克皇帝蒙特祖马（Montezuma）在特诺奇蒂特兰大城（现墨西哥城）外的堤道上相遇。这是历史上最著名的会面之一。这绝对是一个非凡的历史时刻。我的意思是，我想这大概是欧洲人有史以来最接近与外星人接触的时刻了。顺便说一句，对于中美洲人来说也是如此。这种文明的碰撞，这两个人的会面，引发了太多的争论。这不仅仅是两个人的会面，它现在承载了太多的包袱，不是吗？因为这是殖民主义、欧洲帝国主义以及我们星球两大陆块——旧世界与新世界——之间哥伦布大交换的奠基时刻。
exchange of viruses, foods, habits, all of these kinds of things. So it's an incredibly loaded moment. And to write about it for children also reminds you that it's an extraordinary adventure story, but also a very tragic adventure. I mean, it's a story not just of adventure, but of horror as well. And actually to balance all that for kind of 10-year-old readers is a massive challenge. Because it's a story that at the moment is very, very contested. I mean, the issue of whether it is a great adventure story, even that is up for grabs. And almost every aspect of it is furiously debated. And it's a very, very kind of live historiographical area. So there are a number of really quite radically revisionist books have come out recently about it.
病毒、食物、习惯等等的交换。所以这是一个极其沉重的时刻。为孩子们写这段历史也提醒你，这既是一个非凡的冒险故事，也是一个非常悲剧的冒险。我的意思是，这不仅是一个关于冒险的故事，也是一个关于恐怖的故事。实际上，要为10岁的读者平衡所有这些内容是一个巨大的挑战。因为这是一个目前非常有争议的故事。我的意思是，关于它是否是一个伟大的冒险故事，甚至这一点都存在争议。几乎每一个方面都在激烈地争论。这是一个非常活跃的历史学领域。所以最近出现了一些非常激进的修正主义书籍。
So it's simultaneously a thrilling story, but also kind of mysterious in the way that, say, the truth of the Cathars or the origins of Islam, which are other fields of historical inquiry that likewise, scholars have quite radically revised over recent years. So it's a doubly thrilling episode, I think. It is. I agree with you. So it reminds me, when I was writing it, on the surface, it looks like the story of Alexander the Great. So a huge epic journey, lots of battles, adventures, meeting strange people, all of this. And the Spanish themselves, Sir Hernan Cortes, they undoubtedly had that at the back of their minds. I mean, they were really interested in kind of classical parallels.
所以它既是一个惊心动魄的故事，又在某种程度上充满了神秘感，就像卡特里派（Cathars）的真相或伊斯兰教的起源一样，这些都是历史研究领域，近年来学者们同样对其进行了相当激进的修正。所以我认为这是一个双重惊心动魄的篇章。确实。我同意你的看法。这让我想起，我在写它的时候，从表面上看，它看起来像是亚历山大大帝的故事。一段宏大的史诗旅程，大量的战斗、冒险、遇见陌生人，所有这些。而西班牙人自己，埃尔南·科尔特斯爵士，他们无疑在脑海深处有着这些想法。我的意思是，他们对古典的类比非常感兴趣。
They're kind of cosplaying as Romans and Greeks, aren't they, throughout the whole thing? Absolutely, they are. But then, as you say, there's this additional dimension, which is that the story that has come down to us, and lots of people already know some of the lineaments of that story, so they'll know the Aztecs thought the Spanish were gods. The Aztecs surrendered their kingdom because they were so transfixed with fear because the coming of the Spanish had been foretold, all of this stuff. A huge amount of that traditional story is probably completely wrong. And on top of that,
他们在整个过程中都在扮演罗马人和希腊人，不是吗？绝对是这样。但正如你所说，还有一个额外的维度，那就是流传给我们的故事，很多人已经知道那个故事的一些轮廓，所以他们会知道阿兹特克人认为西班牙人是神。阿兹特克人因为极度恐惧而投降，因为西班牙人的到来早已被预言，所有这些东西。这些传统故事中有很大一部分可能是完全错误的。而且最重要的是，
the Spanish sources, they may be lying to us. They may have been lying to themselves about what happened, but they also may have completely misunderstood what was happening. So our glimpses of the story are always through kind of dirty window panes where we're struggling to make out what's really going on. And that's the fun of it. Yeah. Telling an adventure story that's also a mystery story where you can't actually be sure who is on whose side, who's calling the shots, what's actually going on here. And that's what makes it such a riveting episode of human history, I think. And also, I guess, an aspect of it that is less a feature of the children's book, but will be, I guess, something that will be preying on the minds of everyone listening to
西班牙人的资料，他们可能在撒谎。他们可能对自己所发生的事情撒了谎，但他们也可能完全误解了正在发生的事情。所以我们对这个故事的了解总是透过一层肮脏的窗玻璃，我们努力想看清到底发生了什么。而这正是它的乐趣所在。是的。讲述一个既是冒险故事又是悬疑故事的故事，你无法确定谁站在哪一边，谁在发号施令，到底发生了什么。我认为这正是它成为人类历史上如此引人入胜的篇章的原因。而且，我想，还有一个方面，虽然在儿童读物中表现得较少，但我想这会是所有听众心中挥之不去的问题，
this, is that these questions about, did Moctezuma surrender to Cortes? Did the Aztecs think that the Spaniards were gods? All these kinds of questions. These are not just about what happened in the early 16th century. These reverberate into the present day. So they are politically incredibly sensitive. And so that is also a huge part of this story. And I think that just before we get onto the story, one other thing that we should clear up is that this is an episode where even what you should be calling the various people is incredibly complex. So we're going to be calling them the Aztecs. Is that right? So the word the Aztecs was coined, what is it, 19th century?
那就是关于蒙特祖马是否向科尔特斯投降了？阿兹特克人是否认为西班牙人是神？所有这些问题。这些不仅仅是关于16世纪初发生了什么。它们在今天依然产生回响。所以它们在政治上极其敏感。这也是这个故事的重要组成部分。我想在进入故事之前，我们还应该澄清一件事，那就是这是一个连如何称呼各方人物都极其复杂的故事。所以我们要称他们为阿兹特克人。对吗？所以“阿兹特克人”这个词是19世纪才创造出来的，是吗？
18th century. And then popularized in the 19th as a way of distinguishing the Mexica. So the people who live in Tenochtitlan in the Valley of Mexico, from modern Mexicans. But you're right, they never called themselves the Aztecs, rather like the Vikings didn't call themselves the Vikings, I suppose. So we'll call them Aztecs. But it'd be weird if you don't use... If people are interested in Aztec society, we had one of the great historians of the Aztecs, Camilla Townsend, in one of our early episodes
18世纪。然后在19世纪普及开来，作为一种将墨西哥谷特诺奇蒂特兰的居民（墨西加人）与现代墨西哥人区分开来的方式。但你是对的，他们从不自称为阿兹特克人，就像维京人并不自称为维京人一样，我想。所以我们会称他们为阿兹特克人。但如果不使用这个词会很奇怪……如果人们对阿兹特克社会感兴趣，我们在《历史的余味》早期节目中曾邀请过阿兹特克研究的伟大历史学家之一，卡米拉·汤森（Camilla Townsend）。
of The Rest is History. And her book, Fifth Son, wonderful book, the subtitle is A New History of the Aztecs or the Aztec World or whatever. Yes. And I remember when she came on, we discussed this and we agreed. And I think that if Camilla Townsend, whose book I cannot recommend highly enough, on a bonus episode, Dominic, I listed the five great books that have influenced me. I think if there was room for a sixth, I might well include The Fifth Son. I think it's fat good a book. So if it's good enough for Camilla Townsend, I think it's good enough for us to call them the Aztecs. One other, the names of the two great protagonists in this, you've called him Montezuma. I've called him Moctezuma. Which should we go for? Montezuma? Well, if we call him Montezuma, that's fine. Or Moctezuma. The funny thing is he wasn't called
她的书《第五个儿子》（Fifth Son），一本精彩的书，副标题是《阿兹特克人或阿兹特克世界的新历史》之类的。是的。我记得她来的时候，我们讨论过这个问题，我们达成了一致。我想，如果卡米拉·汤森的书——我极力推荐——在加更节目中，多米尼克，我列出了影响我的五本伟大的书。我想如果有第六个位置，我可能会把《第五个儿子》也列进去。我认为它是一本非常好的书。所以如果它对卡米拉·汤森来说足够好，我想我们称他们为阿兹特克人也足够了。还有一件事，这两个伟大主角的名字，你称他为蒙特祖马（Montezuma）。我称他为莫克特祖马（Moctezuma）。我们该选哪个？蒙特祖马？好吧，如果我们叫他蒙特祖马，那没问题。或者莫克特祖马。有趣的是他并不叫
either. No, of course not. It's a very, very long Nahuatl name. I'll tell you what he was called. He was called Motecuzoma Xocoyotzin. I mean, I think that's a mouthful and people won't know who we're talking about. Montezuma is the most common in English. Okay. Well, let's call him Montezuma. And Cortes, the Spanish leader, you've called him Hernan Cortes, but he's more probably Hernando or even Fernando. Is that right? Yes, exactly. He was probably christened Hernando, but most people call him Hernan. So everybody's name is wrong, basically. Everybody's name is wrong and every aspect of the story is contested.
这两个名字。不，当然不是。这是一个非常非常长的纳瓦特尔语名字。我告诉你他叫什么。他叫莫特库佐马·索科约特辛（Motecuzoma Xocoyotzin）。我的意思是，我觉得这太拗口了，人们不知道我们在说谁。蒙特祖马在英语中最常见。好吧。那我们就叫他蒙特祖马。而科尔特斯，西班牙的领袖，你称他为埃尔南·科尔特斯，但他更可能是埃尔南多（Hernando）甚至费尔南多（Fernando）。对吗？是的，没错。他可能受洗名为埃尔南多，但大多数人叫他埃尔南。所以基本上每个人的名字都错了。每个人的名字都错了，故事的每一个方面都存在争议。
So that's what makes it kind of fun. What fun. Okay, well, let's kick off then. So should we begin with Cortez? I think it does make sense. Because we have looked at the Aztecs in that earlier episode we did very much earlier, which if you haven't heard, we commend to you. So let's look at Cortés. So Cortés is the protagonist. Cortés drives the story, really. Or does he, Dominic? Because again, that's something that's contested as well, isn't it?
所以这让它变得很有趣。多有趣啊。好吧，那我们开始吧。我们应该从科尔特斯开始吗？我认为这很有道理。因为我们在之前做的早期节目中已经详细探讨过阿兹特克人了，如果你还没听过，我们推荐你去听。那么让我们看看科尔特斯。所以科尔特斯是主角。科尔特斯确实推动了故事的发展。或者他真的推动了吗，多米尼克？因为同样，这也是有争议的，不是吗？
It is. So we'll come to that later. Well, let's pretend that he is for the time being. And let's put Cortés into his context. There's a wonderful book called Conquistadores by Fernando Cervantes, who's a Mexican historian. And one of the things he really says is people want stereotypes and caricature of the Aztecs. Now they do that with the Spaniards and they just say, oh, they're terribly greedy. They're rapacious, all of this kind of thing. And actually you have to understand them in their world. So Cortes is probably born in 1484 or 1485. And Tom,
确实。所以我们稍后再谈。好吧，我们暂时假定他是主角。让我们把科尔特斯置于他的背景中。有一本精彩的书叫《征服者》（Conquistadores），作者是墨西哥历史学家费尔南多·塞万提斯（Fernando Cervantes）。他真正说的一点是，人们想要阿兹特克人的刻板印象和漫画。现在他们对西班牙人也这样做，他们只是说，哦，他们太贪婪了。他们贪得无厌，诸如此类。实际上你必须在他们的世界里理解他们。所以科尔特斯可能出生于1484年或1485年。汤姆，
that makes him a direct contemporary, a friend of the rest of his history, Catherine of Aragon. But he's born in a much more obscure world. He's born in Extremadura, which is on the far fringe of Spain near the Spanish border. His father, Martin Cortes, boasted of being a Hidalgo, being a knight, but probably was sort of fallen from grace a bit, impecunious kind of gentry. People used to say of him, he doesn't even have enough money to own his own horse, this kind of thing. So Hidalgo is a son of somebody who counts as something, basically.
这使他成为《历史的余味》的直接同时代人，也是阿拉贡的凯瑟琳（Catherine of Aragon）的朋友。但他出生在一个更加默默无闻的世界。他出生在埃斯特雷马杜拉（Extremadura），位于西班牙边缘，靠近葡萄牙边境。他的父亲马丁·科尔特斯（Martin Cortes）自称是伊达尔戈（Hidalgo），即骑士，但可能已经没落了，是贫困的乡绅。人们过去常说他，他甚至没有足够的钱买一匹属于自己的马，诸如此类。所以伊达尔戈基本上就是某个有身份的人的儿子。
Exactly. Yes. And Catalina, Cortes's mother, she is related to a very well-known family now, a family from just up the road in Trujillo, because they're in Medellin in extra Majura. The family she's related to are called the Pizarro's. So Cortes is a distant relative of the Pizarro brothers who, of course, will go on to be instrumental in the conquest of Peru, which is an extraordinary kind of coincidence. The Cortes are not incredibly poor. They probably owned a beehive and a little mill and a vineyard, and they had a house in the center of Medellin. Medellin itself, and I think this actually
没错。是的。而卡塔琳娜（Catalina），科尔特斯的母亲，她与现在一个非常著名的家族有亲戚关系，一个来自特鲁希略（Trujillo）不远处的家族，因为他们住在埃斯特雷马杜拉的麦德林（Medellin）。她有亲戚关系的家族叫皮萨罗（Pizarro）家族。所以科尔特斯是皮萨罗兄弟的远亲，他们当然会继续在秘鲁的征服中发挥关键作用，这是一种非凡的巧合。科尔特斯一家并不极其贫穷。他们可能拥有一个蜂箱、一个小磨坊和一个葡萄园，他们在麦德林市中心有一所房子。麦德林本身，我认为这实际上
probably matters, Medellin is a violent place. It's a place where violence is not uncommon because it's on the frontier. It is famous in Spain for its lawlessness and its feuding and its faction fighting and punch-ups in the town square and stabbings and things like this. It has lots of stalks as well. And lots of castles. Yeah. So there's lots of castles in the area, very famous for it.
可能很重要，麦德林是一个暴力的地方。这是一个暴力并不罕见的地方，因为它处于边境。它在西班牙以无法无天、世仇、派系斗争、城镇广场上的斗殴、刺伤等事件而闻名。它也有很多鹳。还有很多城堡。是的。所以该地区有很多城堡，非常出名。
Hugh Thomas, who wrote a huge book on the conquest of Mexico that I think a lot of historians would now say has some sort of elements that are probably not quite right because he takes everything the Spanish say really on trust. He says of Cortes, Cortes emerged from a world of rebellion, war, and conspiracy, second to none. So that gives you a sort of sense of the immediate context in which he is growing up. And actually, there are quite a few conquistadors who come from that world in extra madura. This kind of hard landscape, unforgiving, lots of feuding, all of this stuff. And Cortés is growing up during the period in Spanish history known as the Reconquista. So when he is seven or eight years old, he and his
休·托马斯（Hugh Thomas）写了一本关于墨西哥征服的巨著，我想很多历史学家现在会说其中有一些部分可能不太正确，因为他完全相信西班牙人所说的一切。他评价科尔特斯说，科尔特斯从一个叛乱、战争和阴谋的世界中脱颖而出，无人能及。这让你对他在成长过程中所处的直接环境有了一种感觉。实际上，有很多征服者来自埃斯特雷马杜拉的那个世界。这种坚硬、无情、充满世仇的景观。科尔特斯是在西班牙历史上被称为“收复失地运动”（Reconquista）的时期长大的。所以当他七八岁时，他和他的
family must have heard news of the fall of Granada further south in 1492. So this is the period when the Spanish, well, I say the Spanish, when the armies of Castile, newly allied through marriage to Aragon, so through the marriage of Ferdinand and Isabella, Christian Catholic monarchs, when they are carrying the gospel of A, Christianity, and B, Spain and sort of Spanishness, they're carrying it south. They are conquering Muslim towns. Ferdinand of Aragon is possessed.
家人一定听到了1492年格拉纳达（Granada）在南方陷落的消息。所以这是西班牙——好吧，我说是西班牙，当卡斯蒂利亚的军队，通过与阿拉贡的联姻，即费迪南德和伊莎贝拉（Ferdinand and Isabella）——天主教君主的婚姻，新近结盟时——当他们带着A、基督教和B、西班牙及西班牙精神的福音向南推进时。他们正在征服穆斯林城镇。阿拉贡的费迪南德被附身了。
We talked about this in our Columbus episodes of this great sense of Christian mission. He believes that it's his destiny to unite not just Spain, but actually- Conquer Jerusalem in the long run. Yeah. The Mediterranean world in the name of God, that one day a monarch will do this, and why shouldn't it be him? They take Granada, the last outpost of what would once have been called Moorish rule, and they start to have forced conversions of Muslims. And of course, famously Ferdinand and Isabella expelled the Jews. So there's a sense of religious militancy there when Cortes is growing up. That is very important. Tom, I can see you're itching to say something.
我们在哥伦布的节目中谈到了这种伟大的基督教使命感。他相信他的命运不仅是统一西班牙，而且实际上——从长远来看征服耶路撒冷。是的。以神的名义征服地中海世界，总有一天会有君主这样做，为什么不能是他呢？他们夺取了格拉纳达，曾经被称为摩尔人统治的最后一个前哨，他们开始强迫穆斯林改宗。当然，众所周知，费迪南德和伊莎贝拉驱逐了犹太人。所以科尔特斯成长时有一种宗教激进主义。这非常重要。汤姆，我看得出你急于说些什么。
Is it true that Cortes' father was actually there? I've read conflicting reports on this. I think it probably isn't true. So Cortes's life, his early life, isn't completely obscure and uneventful and unexciting. Yeah. Because why would people record it? I just wonder though, because the surrender of Boabdil, as he comes to be called, the King of Granada, he marches out and he hands over the keys of the Alhambra to Ferdinand and Isabella. And then he goes off and he bursts into tears about it. And this is the Moors, the last sigh, as in the Rushdie novel. And this portrayal of a weak, tearful king surrendering. I mean, would this be part of the story that Cortez is growing up with?
科尔特斯的父亲真的在那里吗？我读过关于此的相互矛盾的报道。我想这可能不是真的。所以科尔特斯的生活，他早年的生活，并不完全是默默无闻、平淡无奇和乏味的。是的。因为人们为什么要记录它呢？但我只是好奇，因为博阿布迪尔（Boabdil）——后来被称为格拉纳达国王——的投降，他走出来，把阿尔罕布拉宫（Alhambra）的钥匙交给了费迪南德和伊莎贝拉。然后他走开了，为此泪流满面。这就是摩尔人的最后一声叹息，正如拉什迪（Rushdie）的小说中所写的那样。这种对一个软弱、流泪的国王投降的描绘。我的意思是，这会是科尔特斯成长过程中故事的一部分吗？
That's very well observed, Tom. That's very well observed. I hadn't thought of that, but that's a really good point. Yeah, there are a lot of formulas in the story of the conquest of the Aztecs and the conquest of Mexico, the so-called conquest of Mexico. There are a lot of devices that you can recognize from medieval chronicles, classical tales, biblical tales, and you start to think, did that really happen? And I wonder, yes, the image of that non-Christian ruler who bursts into tears and surrenders his kingdom. Cortez has grown up with that story. And the listeners should bear that in mind for when we come to later on. So what do we know about Cortez? We know he probably, when he was young, did some stuff in the local church of St. Martin. He's clearly literate.
观察得非常仔细，汤姆。观察得非常仔细。我没想过这一点，但这确实是一个很好的观点。是的，在阿兹特克征服和墨西哥征服——所谓的墨西哥征服——的故事中有很多公式。有很多你可以从中世纪编年史、古典故事、圣经故事中识别出来的手段，你开始思考，那真的发生了吗？我想是的，那个非基督徒统治者泪流满面并交出王国的形象。科尔特斯是伴随着那个故事长大的。听众在后面听到相关内容时应该记住这一点。那么我们对科尔特斯了解多少呢？我们知道他年轻时可能在当地的圣马丁教堂做过一些事情。他显然识字。
He can read and write. He's said to be quite pious. There's no reason to doubt that he would be pious. I mean, lots of people at the time would be pious. Nothing exceptional about that. But he really doesn't want to be a priest because he takes a different path. Now, I said he's literate. That's really important because he's obviously reading things.
他会读写。据说他相当虔诚。没有理由怀疑他不虔诚。我的意思是，当时很多人都很虔诚。这没什么特别的。但他真的不想成为一名牧师，因为他选择了另一条路。现在，我说他识字。这非常重要，因为他显然在阅读一些东西。
It's an age not just of ballads, but of books. And it's an age of chivalric romances. We talked about this in our Columbus episodes. So Cortes would undoubtedly be familiar with the most popular romance of the day, which is called Tiron Le Blanc, Tiron the White. And it's the story of Christian knights fighting the Ottomans. They're kind of recapturing Constantinople or something. Constantinople, yeah, they do. Yeah. And carrying out amazing feats, sort of scaling castle walls and marrying maidens and defeating infidels and all this sort of stuff there's also a book called amadis de gaula again a story about knights fantastical lands and actually one of the
这是一个不仅有民谣，而且有书籍的时代。这是一个骑士浪漫文学的时代。我们在哥伦布的节目中谈到过这一点。所以科尔特斯无疑会熟悉当时最流行的浪漫小说，叫《白骑士蒂朗》（Tirant lo Blanc）。这是关于基督教骑士与奥斯曼帝国作战的故事。他们正在收复君士坦丁堡之类的。君士坦丁堡，是的，他们做到了。是的。并执行惊人的壮举，比如攀登城堡墙壁、娶少女、击败异教徒等等。还有一本书叫《阿马迪斯·德·高拉》（Amadis de Gaula），同样是关于骑士、奇幻土地的故事。实际上，其中一个
great conquistador narratives by bernal diaz he says when he gets to the valley of mexico he says it reminded us all of a scene from Amadis. So we got to this place, it's to Palapan, and it looked just like the fantastical castles that we'd all read about, the pyramids. So they go with all that in their heads. I think that's really, really important. And so is this giving the young Cortes this notion of idealgia, this sense that to properly be someone, you have to go out and be a knight errant, be someone who goes out and kind of takes your chances. If you just sit around and do nothing, then you're a nobody. I think so. I think so because he clearly doesn't want to sit around
伟大的征服者叙事者贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯（Bernal Diaz）说，当他到达墨西哥谷时，他说这让我们所有人都想起了《阿马迪斯》中的场景。所以我们到了这个地方，特帕拉潘（Iztapalapa），它看起来就像我们读过的那些奇幻城堡，那些金字塔。所以他们带着所有这些想法前往那里。我认为这非常非常重要。这是否给了年轻的科尔特斯这种“伊达尔戈”的概念，这种感觉：要真正成为一个人，你必须走出去成为一名游侠骑士，成为一个走出去并抓住机会的人。如果你只是坐着什么都不做，那你就是个无名小卒。我想是的。我想是的，因为他显然不想坐着
and do nothing. He goes off, first of all, to Salamanca, a great university in Salamanca, and he does some legal studies. We don't know that he actually did formal kind of training and became a graduate, but he definitely goes to what one of his professors calls a great nursery of scholars and gentlemen. He goes there and he studies. Then after a couple of years, he decides he wants to seek his fortune in some way. He could have gone to Italy. The Spanish are fighting in Italy. And there's some talk that he went to Valencia and thought about taking ship to Naples, but he doesn't end up doing that. He's got a better idea. So this is the late 1490s. Now, Columbus has already discovered or sailed to the New World, and Columbus's monopoly has
什么都不做。他首先去了萨拉曼卡（Salamanca），萨拉曼卡的一所伟大大学，他学习了一些法律。我们不知道他是否真的接受了正式的培训并毕业了，但他确实去了他的一位教授所说的“学者和绅士的伟大摇篮”。他去了那里并学习。几年后，他决定以某种方式寻求财富。他本可以去意大利。西班牙人在意大利作战。有一些传言说他去了瓦伦西亚（Valencia），考虑乘船去那不勒斯（Naples），但他最终没有这样做。他有一个更好的主意。所以这是1490年代末。现在，哥伦布已经发现或航行到了新大陆，哥伦布的垄断权已经被
been scrapped. So lots of Spaniards are now going west to try and seek fortunes of their own. And after a lot of to-ing and fro-ing, Cortes decides that he will go west himself to seek his fortune because a kinsman of his sort of family connection called Nicolás de Abando has been made governor of Hispaniola, of the great island that today is Haiti in the Dominican Republic. And so this would be like in 2060, choosing as a young man to go off to the new colony on Mars. Yes, yes. Musqueville. Right, exactly. It would be like you're in the late 19th century in the United
废除了。所以许多西班牙人现在正向西航行，试图寻求自己的财富。经过一番折腾，科尔特斯决定自己向西航行去寻求财富，因为他的一位亲戚，某种家庭关系叫尼古拉斯·德·奥万多（Nicolás de Ovando），被任命为伊斯帕尼奥拉岛（Hispaniola）的总督，即今天海地和多米尼加共和国所在的伟大岛屿。所以这就像在2060年，作为一个年轻人选择去火星上的新殖民地。是的，是的。马斯克维尔（Musqueville）。对，没错。这就像你在19世纪末的美国
States on the eastern seaboard, and you hear that a relative has become sheriff of a new town in Colorado or something. And there might be gold mines nearby, and you decide to go out and seek your fortune. It's that kind of thing. Except that the sense that they literally know nothing about what might be out there is still absolutely part of the climate. It's incredibly dangerous to cross the seas, and who knows what is waiting for you when you get there? Right, exactly. To go west at this point, I imagine you must have a particular quality of courage. Yes. And I think that tells us something about Cortez's character
东海岸，听说一位亲戚成为了科罗拉多州一个新城镇的警长之类的。附近可能有金矿，你决定出去寻求财富。就是那种事情。除了他们对外面可能有什么一无所知的感觉仍然是气候的一部分。跨越海洋极其危险，谁知道当你到达那里时有什么在等着你？对，没错。在这一点上向西航行，我想你必须具备一种特殊的勇气。是的。我认为这告诉了我们一些关于科尔特斯性格的事情
because his family clearly wants him to be a notary, to be a kind of clerk, like a lawyer. And the point of studying law would be that you would work maybe in the royal bureaucracy or something, expanding royal bureaucracy. Cushy, secure. Yeah. But he doesn't choose that. He's clearly restless and he wants to seek his fortune in some way. So off he goes over the Atlantic. The voyage would take you eight weeks, but it's an established thing by now. Because I said there was a lot of faffing around, he actually doesn't end up going until
因为他的家人显然希望他成为一名公证人，成为一名文员，像律师一样。学习法律的意义在于你可能会在皇家官僚机构中工作，或者类似的东西，扩大皇家官僚机构。舒适、安全。是的。但他没有选择那个。他显然很不安分，想以某种方式寻求财富。所以他跨越大西洋而去。航行需要八周，但这在当时已经是一件既定的事情了。因为我说过有很多折腾，他实际上直到
1506. Because he falls out of somebody's window, doesn't he, whose wife he's trying to seduce. Exactly. Very Don Giovanni behavior. He's either climbing up or climbing down. There are different accounts. Breaks his leg. Breaks his leg. So he ends up pitching up in Hispaniola, in Santo Domingo, in the capital of Hispaniola, where his family connection, Nicolás de Ovando, is the governor
1506年才最终成行。因为他从某人的窗户掉下来了，不是吗，他试图勾引那个人的妻子。没错。非常唐璜（Don Giovanni）的行为。他要么是在爬上去，要么是在爬下来。有不同的说法。摔断了腿。摔断了腿。所以他最终来到了伊斯帕尼奥拉岛，在圣多明各（Santo Domingo），伊斯帕尼奥拉岛的首府，他的家庭关系尼古拉斯·德·奥万多是总督
and has started building the governor's house and a hospital and so on and so forth. And he does a little bit of work for Ovando. He works for a time, it seems, at a sugar mill. And eventually he gets a job as the notary of a new town called Azua de Compostela, which is on the south side of the island, Hispaniola. Just before we talk about how boring his life is, life on Hispaniola is very violent as well. There are about 300 Spaniards on Hispaniola at this point. We talked in the Columbus episodes about the native people, the Tainos. At this point, the Spanish are repressing the Tainos with ferocious, ferocious ruthlessness. They're setting dogs on them. They are rounding them up and making them work in gold mines. The Tainos
并开始建造总督府和医院等等。他为奥万多做了一点工作。他似乎在一家糖厂工作了一段时间。最终他得到了一份工作，成为一个叫阿苏阿德孔波斯特拉（Azua de Compostela）的新城镇的公证人，该镇位于岛的南侧，伊斯帕尼奥拉岛。在我们谈论他的生活有多无聊之前，伊斯帕尼奥拉岛的生活也非常暴力。此时伊斯帕尼奥拉岛上大约有300名西班牙人。我们在哥伦布的节目中谈到了原住民泰诺人（Tainos）。此时，西班牙人正以极其凶残的无情手段镇压泰诺人。他们放狗咬他们。他们把他们围捕起来，强迫他们在金矿工作。泰诺人
are dying in massive numbers because of disease, because their ecosystem has been destroyed, because they're suffering genuinely terrible trauma, mental, psychological trauma, at the collapse of their entire world because of the arrival of all these Europeans. And the poor queen, golden flower, who gets captured and she gets hanged. She does. And actually when Cortes arrived to see Obando, Obando is off dealing with the aftermath of what's happened to this queen. So yes. And the Spanish also, by the way, they've already started to bring in the first African slaves because the Tainos are dying in
因为疾病、因为他们的生态系统被摧毁、因为他们因所有这些欧洲人的到来而导致整个世界崩溃，正遭受着真正可怕的创伤——精神和心理创伤——而大量死亡。还有那位可怜的“金花”女王（Queen Golden Flower），她被俘虏并被绞死了。她确实被绞死了。实际上当科尔特斯到达去见奥万多时，奥万多正在处理这位女王遭遇后的余波。所以是的。顺便说一句，西班牙人也已经开始引入第一批非洲奴隶，因为泰诺人正在
such massive numbers. They say, listen, we've already been using African slaves in the Canary Islands. Cortes would undoubtedly have seen that, by the way. He'd have seen slaves for sale in Seville before he sailed. He would also have probably seen slaves on the docks in the Canary Islands where his ship would have stopped, which was a standard thing on the voyage over. So I said he was brought up in a world of violence. He's seen an awful lot of violence and suffering on Hispaniola. Hispaniola is as close as anywhere in the early 16th century to being kind of hell on earth, I think it's fair to say. However, Cortes' life on Hispaniola is very boring. So Cortes is the notary of this dusty new town, nothing going on there. And actually for somebody who's made this big journey to try and seek his fortune, he's now
大量死亡。他们说，听着，我们已经在加那利群岛使用非洲奴隶了。顺便说一句，科尔特斯无疑见过。他在航行前在塞维利亚见过待售的奴隶。他也可能在加那利群岛的码头上见过奴隶，他的船会在那里停靠，这是航行中的标准程序。所以我说他是在一个充满暴力的世界中长大的。他在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛上看到了大量的暴力和苦难。我认为可以公平地说，伊斯帕尼奥拉岛是16世纪初最接近人间地狱的地方。然而，科尔特斯在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛上的生活非常无聊。所以科尔特斯是这个尘土飞扬的新城镇的公证人，那里什么都没有发生。实际上对于一个为了寻求财富而进行这次大旅行的人来说，他现在
just found himself doing the same thing he would have done back in Spain, basically filling in ledgers and being a pen pusher. But in slightly sweatier circumstances. Exactly. So the glimpses we have of him, he's a womanizer. He likes playing dice and gambling, but that's standard. So he does like gambling. Yeah, he does like gambling. I think that's an important part of his character. He is a gambler and he always will be a gambler. He probably gets into some drunken fights. There's a story that he has a scar on his chin
只是发现自己做着他在西班牙本可以做的同样的事情，基本上是填写账簿和做一个文书工作者。但在稍微更闷热的环境中。没错。所以我们对他的一瞥，他是个花花公子。他喜欢掷骰子和赌博，但这很标准。所以他确实喜欢赌博。是的，他确实喜欢赌博。我认为这是他性格的重要组成部分。他是一个赌徒，而且他永远都会是一个赌徒。他可能卷入了一些醉酒斗殴。有一个故事说他的下巴上有一道伤疤
through having a fight about a woman. But the truth of the matter is, I think there is a sense at the turn of the 1510s that Cortes, this ambitious young man, that his great gamble of crossing the Atlantic rather than getting the cushy job back in Spain, that hasn't really worked. He's kind of going nowhere.
是因为为了一个女人打架。但事实是，我认为在1510年代初有一种感觉，科尔特斯，这个雄心勃勃的年轻人，他跨越大西洋而不是在西班牙找一份舒适工作的巨大赌博，并没有真正奏效。他基本上是一事无成。
So what opportunities are there? Because if Hispaniola has effectively been pacified, is, as you say, turning into hell on earth, what further opportunities for expansion are being provided to someone like Cortes that he can join up with? Well, this is the thing, Tom. So to make sense of the Spanish conquest of the Aztecs, you have to understand that the whole process of conquest and colonization, and this will sound
那么有什么机会呢？因为如果伊斯帕尼奥拉岛实际上已经被平定，正如你所说，正在变成人间地狱，那么像科尔特斯这样的人还有什么进一步的扩张机会可以加入？好吧，就是这样，汤姆。所以要理解西班牙对阿兹特克人的征服，你必须明白整个征服和殖民的过程，这听起来
such a ridiculously tasteless comparison, but it's like an island hopping holiday. The historian Matthew Restle talks about links in a chain. You go to one island and that opens up the next and then the next and so on and so forth. So the next island on is Cuba. And in 1511, Cortes hears that one of the richest men on Hispaniola, who is a landowner called Diego Velazquez, he is going to go off to Cuba in pursuit of a Taino rebel called Hatuey. And once he's got Hatuey, he's going to try and conquer and colonize Cuba, which is also inhabited by Taino people. And Velázquez is an important man to know. He's rich.
是一个极其低俗的比较，但这就像一个跳岛度假。历史学家马修·雷斯特尔（Matthew Restall）谈到了链条中的环节。你去一个岛，那打开了下一个，然后是下一个，以此类推。所以下一个岛是古巴。1511年，科尔特斯听说伊斯帕尼奥拉岛上最富有的人之一，一位名叫迭戈·贝拉斯克斯（Diego Velazquez）的土地所有者，要出发去古巴追捕一名叫哈图伊（Hatuey）的泰诺叛军。一旦他抓住了哈图伊，他就会试图征服和殖民古巴，那里也居住着泰诺人。而贝拉斯克斯是一个值得结识的重要人物。他很富有。
He had fought at Granada. He had been there in the battles against the Moors. He had been on one of Columbus's voyages, I think his second voyage. He's a man of size, isn't he? He's a big, hefty bloke. Yes. He's a jolly man, actually, Velazquez. He's very hospitable. People say he's a good man to know. His dinner party is very good, all this kind of thing. He's going off to Cuba and Cortes thinks, sod the notary job in the middle of nowhere. I'm going to go with him. I'm joining. Yeah.
他在格拉纳达战斗过。他在对抗摩尔人的战斗中在那里。我想他在哥伦布的第二次航行中也在那里。他是一个大块头，不是吗？他是一个大而壮实的人。是的。贝拉斯克斯实际上是一个快乐的人。他非常热情好客。人们说他是一个值得结识的好人。他的晚宴非常好，诸如此类。他要出发去古巴，科尔特斯想，去他的那个偏僻地方的公证人工作。我要和他一起去。我加入。是的。
So he goes with him. Now, Hathaway has gone off to Cuba and there's an interesting thing here, which is a preview of what is coming. There's a famous story that Hathaway arrives in Cuba, and he meets up with the local Taínos. Clearly, they must speak the same language. And he says to them, there are these fellows coming from Hispaniola. They are terrible men. They're the Spanish. And he says, they are obsessed with this god. They have a god that they worship. And points to a basket and he says this is the god of the christians this is the god they are desperate to get their hands on and the basket is full of gold yeah well whether this story happened who knows or whether it's one of these many many tales that are talked and there's another famous line he says isn't there where he finally gets captured and he's about to be burnt alive. And one of the friars who's come with Velázquez says to him, for goodness sake, be baptized and then you'll go to heaven. And Hathaway says, well, who will be in heaven? Will you Spaniards be in heaven? He says,
所以他和他一起去了。现在，哈图伊已经去了古巴，这里有一件有趣的事情，这是即将发生的事情的预演。有一个著名的故事说哈图伊到达古巴，他遇到了当地的泰诺人。显然，他们一定说同一种语言。他对他们说，有这些家伙从伊斯帕尼奥拉岛过来。他们是可怕的人。他们是西班牙人。他说，他们痴迷于这个神。他们有一个他们崇拜的神。并指着一个篮子说，这就是基督徒的神，这就是他们拼命想得到的东西，篮子里装满了黄金。是的，好吧，这个故事是否发生过谁知道呢，或者它是否是那些被谈论的众多故事之一。还有一个著名的台词，不是吗，当他最终被俘虏并即将被活活烧死时。随贝拉斯克斯而来的修士之一对他说，看在上帝的份上，受洗吧，然后你就会上天堂。哈图伊说，好吧，谁会在天堂？你们西班牙人会在天堂吗？他说，
yes, of course, we'll all be in heaven. He says, in that case, I will not ever, ever be baptized because I do not want to spend eternity with the Spaniards. Exactly. Yeah. I'd rather be in hell than have eternal life with monsters like you. People like you. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. And actually, we lose sight of Cortez on Cuba. But what undoubtedly happened is a process of colonization that was extremely brutal. So I will mention one character who's going to be very, very important in Cortez's story, who we know was there. This is a guy called Panfilo Narvaez. And Panfilo Narvaez
是的，当然，我们都会在天堂。他说，那样的话，我永远永远不要受洗，因为我不想和西班牙人一起度过永恒。没错。是的。我宁愿下地狱也不愿和你们这样的怪物一起获得永生。像你们这样的人。是的。是的，没错。实际上，我们在古巴失去了科尔特斯的踪迹。但无疑发生的是一个极其残酷的殖民过程。所以我将提到一个在科尔特斯的故事中将非常非常重要的人物，我们知道他在那里。这是一个叫潘菲洛·德·纳尔瓦埃斯（Panfilo Narvaez）的人。而潘菲洛·德·纳尔瓦埃斯
had already been involved in the conquest of Jamaica. And he had kind of waded through blood on Jamaica. And he did so again on Cuba. And there's a very famous scene where he goes into a village and the villagers have all prepared food to welcome him and his troops. And there's a very famous scene where he goes into a village and the villagers have all prepared food to welcome him and his troops. And it's been negotiated by a friar and he orders his troops to kill everybody anyway. And the friar bursts sort of into tears and goes up to him and begs for these people's lives. And Narvaez laughs at him and says, don't you like what our Spanish lads have done? And all this kind of thing. And the friar ends up being Bartolome de las Casas, the great kind of spokesman for the native peoples of the Caribbean, who says they have souls. They could be good Christians.
已经参与了牙买加的征服。他在牙买加上涉过血泊。他在古巴又做了一次。有一个非常著名的场景，他走进一个村庄，村民们都准备了食物来欢迎他和他的部队。有一个非常著名的场景，他走进一个村庄，村民们都准备了食物来欢迎他和他的部队。这是由一位修士协商的，但他还是命令他的部队杀死了所有人。修士流着泪走上前去，乞求这些人的生命。纳尔瓦埃斯嘲笑他，说，你不喜欢我们西班牙小伙子做的事吗？诸如此类。而那位修士最终成为了巴托洛梅·德·拉斯·卡萨斯（Bartolome de las Casas），加勒比原住民的伟大代言人，他说他们有灵魂。他们可以是好的基督徒。
You shouldn't be enslaving them and butchering them and all this kind of thing. And Cortes would have sailed out with Las Casas had he not broken his leg, jumping out of that woman's bedroom. And they will know each other throughout their lives. They may well have been at university in Salamanca at the same time. Yeah. Probably not great friends, but they might have come across each other. But Narbáez, he will come back. But also Las Casas, because his comments on Cortes' claims and stories are a kind of rare example of a Spaniard expressing suspicion of what Cortes is saying.
你不应该奴役他们、屠杀他们等等。如果科尔特斯没有因为从那个女人的卧室跳出来摔断腿，他本会和拉斯·卡萨斯一起航行。他们一生都会认识彼此。他们很可能在萨拉曼卡大学时就在同一时间。是的。可能不是好朋友，但他们可能遇到过。但纳尔瓦埃斯，他会回来的。还有拉斯·卡萨斯，因为他对科尔特斯的说法和故事的评论是西班牙人对科尔特斯所说的话表示怀疑的一个罕见例子。
Yes. So fascinating. Exactly. Exactly. So Cortes is there. Cuba has been conquered. Everything has worked out as far as he's concerned. Velazquez hands out what are called encomiendas to all his comrades.
是的。太迷人了。没错。没错。所以科尔特斯在那里。古巴已经被征服了。就他而言，一切都很顺利。贝拉斯克斯把所谓的“监护征赋制”（encomiendas）分发给他的所有同志。
So these are little farms and estates of their own. This is again a preview of what will happen eventually in Mexico and other parts of Latin America. There's already a sort of exchange where they are bringing in pigs, sheep, crops, and things like that from Europe. So transforming the landscape and sending back to Europe shipments of gold for the Spanish monarchs who are demanding money the whole time. Now we've invested in these operations. We want to see a return. So they're the shareholders. Exactly. A good way for listeners who are unfamiliar with the story to think about it is, I mean, it sounds like such a weird way to think about it, but I was thinking about the film, The Social Network and the foundation of Facebook and all these companies, all these rival kind of tech
所以这些是他们自己的小农场和庄园。这又是墨西哥和拉丁美洲其他地区最终将发生的事情的预演。已经有一种交换，他们正在从欧洲引入猪、羊、农作物等。所以改变了景观，并向西班牙君主送回了黄金，他们一直在要求钱。现在我们已经投资了这些行动。我们想看到回报。所以他们是股东。没错。对于不熟悉这个故事的听众来说，一个好的思考方式是，我的意思是，这听起来是一个很奇怪的思考方式，但我当时在想电影《社交网络》（The Social Network）和Facebook的创立，所有这些公司，所有这些竞争的科技
entrepreneurs at the wild west of technology. They're seeking investment, but they need to show a return. They've all got lawyers who are going to end up suing each other and fighting each other and all this kind of thing. And they sometimes team up, but they're always ultimately out for themselves. That is exactly the same ethos as the one that the conquistadors. And you need to decide, are you going to sign up with a tech company that's growing or are you going to blaze your own path? And that's basically the problem for Cortez. He's not yet in a position to be his own agent. No, he's not. So he's kind of Velazquez's man. He has his own country estate. He seems to have had his own little iron foundry. He may have had his
企业家在科技的狂野西部。他们正在寻求投资，但他们需要展示回报。他们都有律师，最终会互相起诉、互相争斗等等。他们有时会合作，但他们最终总是为了自己。这与征服者的精神完全一样。你需要决定，你是要加入一家正在成长的科技公司，还是开辟自己的道路？这基本上是科尔特斯的问题。他还没有处于成为自己代理人的位置。不，他没有。所以他基本上是贝拉斯克斯的人。他有自己的乡村庄园。他似乎有自己的小铸铁厂。他可能有自己的
own little gold mine, or at least a place where he was digging for gold. At first, he is Velazquez's secretary. Velazquez starts to build his own capital at Santiago de Cuba. Cortes is his secretary. But there are some signs that Cortes actually doesn't like being somebody else's creature. He wants to be his own man. So there's a massive row they have. Cortes has been flirting or carrying on with this woman called Catalina Suarez, and she thinks he'd promised to marry her. He says, no, no, no, I'm never marrying you. Velazquez throws him into prison, actually sacks him from his job and stuff. And afterwards, Cortes basically has to apologize. He has to marry her. And he's described afterwards as being very downcast and humble, as if he'd been the lowliest servant.
小金矿，或者至少是一个他挖掘黄金的地方。起初，他是贝拉斯克斯的秘书。贝拉斯克斯开始在古巴圣地亚哥（Santiago de Cuba）建立自己的首都。科尔特斯是他的秘书。但有一些迹象表明科尔特斯实际上不喜欢成为别人的傀儡。他想成为自己的主人。所以他们发生了一场巨大的争吵。科尔特斯一直在和这个叫卡塔琳娜·苏亚雷斯（Catalina Suarez）的女人调情或交往，她认为他答应娶她。他说，不，不，不，我永远不会娶你。贝拉斯克斯实际上把他关进了监狱，解雇了他的工作等等。事后，科尔特斯基本上不得不道歉。他不得不娶她。之后他被描述为非常沮丧和谦卑，好像他是一个最卑微的仆人。
And Velazquez seems to forgive him and makes him the chief magistrate again of Santiago. But Cortes clearly has a bit of a grudge about this. He's basically been forced to marry this woman that he didn't want to marry. And humiliated publicly. And he's been humiliated and he still has not, you know, he is the assistant to the CEO. He's the PA rather than being the CEO himself, which is what he wants to be. And so presumably he knows that the only way that he can kind of escape from that subordinate position and establish a command for himself is if there are lands even further west. And so the Spanish having reached Cuba, presumably are, well, Columbus had tracked the coast of what we now know is Central America. So the Spaniards know that there are more lands out there. Should we take a break at this point? And when we come back, look at the process by which the Spanish and in due course, Cortez himself arrive on the shores of continental America.
维拉斯奎兹似乎原谅了他，并让他重新担任圣地亚哥的首席地方法官。但科尔特斯显然对此怀恨在心。他基本上是被迫娶了这个他不想娶的女人，而且在公开场合受尽羞辱。他一直受到羞辱，而且他仍然，你知道，他只是首席执行官的助理。他只是个私人助理，而不是他想成为的首席执行官。所以大概他知道，想要摆脱那种从属地位并建立自己的指挥权，唯一的办法就是去往更西边的地方。因此，西班牙人到达古巴后，大概是，好吧，哥伦布曾沿着我们现在所知的中美洲海岸航行。所以西班牙人知道那里还有更多的土地。我们现在要休息一下吗？回来后，我们将看看西班牙人以及后来的科尔特斯本人到达美洲大陆海岸的过程。
So we'll see you in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场演出门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Or like Stout Cortez when with eagle eyes he stared at the Pacific, and all his men looked at each other with a wild surmise, silent upon a peak in Darien. So that, Dominic, final words of John Keats' great sonnet on first looking into Chapman's Homer, where he compares his experience reading a translation of Homer to Stout Cortez, the first European to gaze out from a peak in Darien across to the Pacific Ocean. And so that's an allusion to a great moment of discovery in 1513, except that Keats gets it wrong, doesn't he? Because Stout Cortez is not part of the expedition
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。或者像坚毅的科尔特斯，当他用鹰眼凝视太平洋时，他所有的部下都面面相觑，怀着狂野的猜测，在达连的一座山峰上沉默不语。多米尼克，这就是约翰·济慈那首伟大的十四行诗《初读查普曼译荷马》的最后几句，他将自己阅读荷马译本的经历比作坚毅的科尔特斯，他是第一个从达连山峰眺望太平洋的欧洲人。所以这是一个对1513年伟大发现时刻的典故，只不过济慈弄错了，不是吗？因为坚毅的科尔特斯并不是那次探险队的一员，
that sees the Pacific Ocean for the first time. No. So the guy who actually did it was a guy called Basco Nunez de Balboa. So this is while Cortez and Co. were kind of rampaging through Cuba. So Balboa had gone to Panama. He doesn't know Panama as part of the American mainland.
那次探险队第一次看到了太平洋。不。所以真正做到这一点的人是一个叫巴斯克·努涅斯·德·巴尔博亚的人。这发生在科尔特斯和他的同伙在古巴横冲直撞的时候。所以巴尔博亚去了巴拿马。他不知道巴拿马是美洲大陆的一部分。
As far as he's concerned, it's probably like a big island, a big, long, narrow island. And he had crossed the jungle and he had been the first European to lay eyes on the waters of the Pacific. And Balboa is one of many such people that historian Matthew Restle calls them armed entrepreneurs who have set out from Spain, who have come to the Caribbean, and then they're using it as a jumping off point. I use the phrase island hopping in the first half of this episode. They've used it as a jumping off point
在他看来，这可能就像一个大岛，一个又大又长又窄的岛。他穿过了丛林，成为了第一个亲眼目睹太平洋水域的欧洲人。巴尔博亚是历史学家马修·雷斯特尔所说的“武装企业家”中的一员，他们从西班牙出发，来到加勒比海，并将其作为跳板。我在本集前半部分用了“跳岛”这个词。他们把它当作跳板，
to find new territories. So during the 1510s, while Cortes is kind of there being pushed around by Diego Velázquez in Santiago de Cuba. Being made to marry women and- Exactly. Blot a dot and-
去寻找新的领土。所以在1510年代，当科尔特斯在圣地亚哥-德古巴被迭戈·维拉斯奎兹摆布时。被迫娶妻，还有——没错。涂掉一个点，然后——
And fill in for him. Yeah, oh, terrible. Some Spanish colonists have landed on the coasts of what we now would call Colombia or Venezuela. There's a guy with a splendid name, Juan Ponce de Leon. Oh, he's the one who goes off looking for the fountain of youth. He does indeed. Yeah. In Florida, right? Yeah. So he has found a massive island, which he calls La Florida, the flowery one,
还要替他顶班。是的，哦，太糟糕了。一些西班牙殖民者登陆了我们现在称之为哥伦比亚或委内瑞拉的海岸。有一个名字很响亮的人，胡安·庞塞·德·莱昂。哦，他就是那个去寻找青春之泉的人。他确实是。在佛罗里达，对吧？是的。所以他发现了一个巨大的岛屿，他称之为“拉佛罗里达”，即“花之岛”，
the place of flowers, which of course is not an island an island it's a peninsula but he thinks it's an island and so i said before but i guess it's known as a great host and he's probably having these dinner parties parties banquets at his house in santiago where they are talking about what is out there to the west and there has been rumors sort of sea captains and sailors say they have seen you know a shape on the horizon which is probably a great land out there maybe another island who knows the local people the tainos such of them that are left they say that there are people who sometimes paddle across and say that it took them six days by canoe and of course the tainos must have come from the American mainland at some point centuries
花之所在，当然那不是一个岛，它是一个半岛，但他以为是一个岛。所以我之前说过，但我猜他被称为一个伟大的主人，他可能在圣地亚哥的家里举办晚宴、宴会，在那里他们谈论西边有什么。有传言说，一些船长和水手说他们看到了，你知道，地平线上有一个形状，那可能是一片广阔的土地，也许是另一个岛，谁知道呢。当地的泰诺人，剩下的那些人，他们说有时会有人划船过来，说他们划独木舟花了六天时间，当然，泰诺人一定是在几个世纪前从美洲大陆过来的。
earlier. So the Spanish are sitting there in Cuba and they are thinking, there must be something there. There's probably something. And in 1517, a guy called Francisco Hernández de Córdoba sets off as an old soldier on a voyage to the west and he finds these little islands finds an island called the Isla Mujeres which is off the coast of what is now Cancun the great resort spring break resort for our American listeners so the island of women the island of women because they get there and they find statues of goddesses. So even at that point, it's pretty obvious, I think, to the Spanish
早些时候。所以西班牙人坐在古巴，他们心想，那里一定有什么东西。可能有什么东西。1517年，一个叫弗朗西斯科·埃尔南德斯·德·科尔多瓦的人作为一名老兵踏上了向西的航程，他发现了这些小岛，发现了一个叫女人岛的地方，它位于现在坎昆的海岸外，那是我们美国听众的春假度假胜地，所以叫女人岛，因为他们到了那里发现了女神的雕像。所以即使在那个时候，我想对西班牙人来说也很明显，
that this is a bit different from the Caribbean, that the people here, who we now know as the Maya, that they have a level of sophistication, shall we say, that is higher. They're technologically more adept. They probably have more stuff than the Tainos. At some point, some people paddle across to Hernandez de Cordova's ships in canoes. These are Maya. And he says, what's the name of this country? And the story goes that their chief says Yucatan. And he says, oh, right, the Yucatan. Brilliant. Great tourist port name. But actually, what the guy was actually saying was something like, I don't know what you're saying.
这与加勒比海有点不同，这里的人，我们现在称之为玛雅人，他们的文明程度，我们姑且这么说，更高。他们在技术上更熟练。他们拥有的东西可能比泰诺人多。在某个时候，一些人划着独木舟来到埃尔南德斯·德·科尔多瓦的船上。这些人是玛雅人。他说，这个国家叫什么名字？故事是说他们的酋长说“尤卡坦”。他说，哦，对了，尤卡坦。太棒了。很棒的旅游港口名字。但实际上，那个人当时说的是类似“我不知道你在说什么”的话。
Or he was saying to his friends, who are these weird fellows? I don't understand what they're going on about. So it's K. That's how it came to be called, the Yucatan. And it's obvious to them when they get to the mainland that there are villages and towns. There are buildings made of stone. There are thatch roofs.
或者他在对他的朋友说，这些奇怪的家伙是谁？我不明白他们在说什么。所以是“K”。这就是它后来被称为尤卡坦的原因。当他们到达大陆时，很明显那里有村庄和城镇。有石头建造的建筑。有茅草屋顶。
There are pyramid temples. This is not Cuba or Hispaniola. This is the big league now. This is sort of proper stuff. They get as far as what's now Campeche, and there they are very discomforted because they see some temples with evidence of sacrifice, possibly human sacrifice. So pools of blood. They meet some priests who basically warn them off and say,
有金字塔神庙。这不是古巴或伊斯帕尼奥拉岛。现在这是大联盟了。这是真正的硬货。他们到达了现在坎昆的坎佩切，在那里他们感到非常不安，因为他们看到了一些有祭祀证据的神庙，可能是人祭。所以有血泊。他们遇到了一些祭司，他们基本上警告他们离开并说，
if you stay here any longer, we'll kill you. How are they saying this? How are they communicating this? This is the thing, Tom. We don't know. There's no way that the Spanish could have... Was it through the language of mime? I fear it was.
如果你再待在这里，我们就杀了你。他们是怎么说的？他们是如何沟通的？这就是问题所在，汤姆。我们不知道。西班牙人不可能……是通过哑剧语言吗？我担心是的。
Yeah, I think there probably is an awful lot of... Physical theatre. It's so interesting because in the accounts that we have you know it's sort of the chieftain said this or whatever but how do they know what i did yeah they have no way of knowing so again this is where the story starts to get so murky so either it's done through physical theater or they are projecting what they think onto what the chief is saying or they're literally just making it all up. Precisely. So all the stuff about human sacrifice is very controversial among historians of the Spanish conquest of the Americas. Because how much of this is true, how much of this is Spanish projection, or how much is this Spanish justification of their bad behavior?
是的，我想可能有很多……肢体剧。这太有趣了，因为在我们现有的记录中，你知道，是酋长说了这个或那个，但他们怎么知道我做了什么？是的，他们根本无法知道。所以这又是故事开始变得模糊的地方，要么是通过肢体剧，要么是他们把自己想的东西投射到酋长说的话上，或者他们干脆就是编造的。确实。所以关于人祭的所有内容在美洲西班牙征服史的历史学家中非常有争议。因为其中有多少是真的，有多少是西班牙人的投射，或者有多少是西班牙人为他们的恶劣行为辩护？
But it's not entirely made up, is it? No, it's not entirely made up. There definitely is human sacrifice. And Andes, he goes further up the coast. At some point, he is attacked by the locals. There's a lot of firing of arrows and hurling of spears. He is badly wounded. His men go back to Cuba.
但它并非完全是编造的，对吧？不，它不是完全编造的。确实有人祭。安德斯，他沿着海岸走得更远。在某个时候，他受到了当地人的攻击。有很多箭矢射出，长矛投掷。他受了重伤。他的部下回到了古巴。
He's not dead yet, but he dies after he gets back to Cuba. However, crucially, when he gets back to Cuba, but before he dies, he says to all the people, the bigwigs that gather around his bedside or whatever, there are temples there. There are towns there. This is a bloody big place. Has he seen gold? I don't think he has seen colossal quantities of gold at this point. The person who sees gold is the person who goes next.
他还没死，但在回到古巴后他就死了。然而，至关重要的是，当他回到古巴，但在他死之前，他告诉所有聚集在他床边的大人物们，那里有神庙。那里有城镇。这是一个该死的大地方。他看到黄金了吗？我不认为他当时看到了大量的黄金。看到黄金的人是下一个去的人。
So Diego Velazquez, who is the governor of Cuba, by the way, for those people who are interested in our pronunciation of Spanish names, we're a very diverse podcast. The rest is history. So we've agreed, haven't we, Tom, to have a lot of linguistic diversity in our Spanish pronunciation. Sometimes we'll do a Castilian accent. Sometimes we'll do accents from Latin America because we want everyone to feel included. Sometimes from Fawlty Towers. association sometimes we'll do a castilian accent sometimes we'll do accents from latin america because we want everyone to feel included sometimes from faulty towers yeah exactly the full the full diverse range exactly sometimes it's andrew sax's manuel sometimes it's the spanish of cervantes you just have to wait and find out which one it's going to be so anyway january 1518, Velazquez thinks, I really want to be the man who finds out what's out there. And he gets his nephew, who is a guy called Juan de Grialba.
所以迭戈·维拉斯奎兹，顺便说一下，他是古巴的总督，对于那些对我们西班牙名字发音感兴趣的人，我们是一个非常多元化的播客。《余谈历史》。所以我们已经商定好了，汤姆，在我们的西班牙语发音中要有很大的语言多样性。有时我们会用卡斯蒂利亚口音。有时我们会用拉丁美洲的口音，因为我们希望每个人都感到被包容。有时来自《弗尔蒂旅馆》。有时我们会用卡斯蒂利亚口音，有时我们会用拉丁美洲的口音，因为我们希望每个人都感到被包容，有时来自《弗尔蒂旅馆》。是的，完全正确，完全多样化的范围，完全正确，有时是安德鲁·萨克斯的曼努埃尔，有时是塞万提斯的西班牙语，你只需要等着看会是哪一个。所以无论如何，1518年1月，维拉斯奎兹心想，我真的很想成为那个发现外面有什么的人。他找了他的侄子，一个叫胡安·德·格里哈尔瓦的人。
And his nephew is this sort of dashing young fellow. He's in his, I think his early twenties or mid twenties. A knight errant type. A knight errant. Yeah, exactly. Grialba gets four ships. He gets 200 men. So it's a big expedition.
他的侄子是一个风度翩翩的年轻人。我想他二十出头或二十五六岁。游侠类型。游侠。是的，完全正确。格里哈尔瓦得到了四艘船。他有200人。所以这是一次大规模的探险。
He has some cannons. He has people with crossbows. He has people with arquebuses who are the kind of, I don't really understand how an arquebus works. It's like an ancestor of a rifle or musket or something, isn't it? Yeah. Kind of. And.
他有一些大炮。他有带弩的人。他有带火绳枪的人，他们是那种，我不太明白火绳枪是怎么工作的。它就像步枪或滑膛枪的祖先，对吧？是的。有点像。而且。
Yeah. I just want to do that sound effect again. And he's got some dogs. He's got horses. I don't know that he does have horses i know he has dogs i'm not certain about horses cortez of course will take horses which are very yes it's crucial part of it so gravel goes off he goes to the island of cozumel which is a great diving destination today he kind of follows anandas to cordoba's route he arrives near campeche he picks
是的。我只是想再做一次那个音效。他还有一些狗。他有马。我不知道他是否有马，我知道他有狗，我不确定是否有马，科尔特斯当然会带马，这是非常，是的，这是至关重要的一部分。所以格里哈尔瓦出发了，他去了科苏梅尔岛，那是今天一个很棒的潜水目的地，他沿着埃尔南德斯·德·科尔多瓦的路线走，他到达了坎佩切附近，他取了
up some water some maya attack him but he fires his cannons and they all run away. He goes all the way around the Yucatan Peninsula. He ends up on the coast of what is now the Mexican state of Tabasco. And there, the people are actually quite friendly and they offer him fish and they offer him beans and stuff like this. He gives them some nice glass beads. Crucially, they give him one or two trinkets of gold. Grijalva thinks, oh, you know, because gold has always been the thing that has really interested the Spanish on Hispaniola and Cuba. People always think the Spanish are driven mad by gold for some demented reason of their own.
一些水，一些玛雅人攻击他，但他发射了大炮，他们都跑了。他绕过了整个尤卡坦半岛。他最终到达了现在墨西哥塔巴斯科州的海岸。在那里，人们实际上非常友好，他们给他提供鱼、豆子之类的东西。他给了他们一些漂亮的玻璃珠。至关重要的是，他们给了他一两件金饰。格里哈尔瓦心想，哦，你知道，因为黄金一直是让西班牙人在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛和古巴真正感兴趣的东西。人们总是认为西班牙人因为某种他们自己的疯狂原因而被黄金逼疯了。
There's actually a really good reason to be interested in gold. Gold is so easily portable and it's also very easily divisible among your company and it doesn't rust. Precisely. divisible among your company and it doesn't rust precisely you can take it back to spain and you can use it to buy you know a nice farm nice estate elevate your family that's the point about gold you know there's no point getting resources that you can't travel with so that's why people want gold so grauver continues on this sort of voyage he finds another island where he's even more discomforted than
实际上，对黄金感兴趣有一个非常好的理由。黄金非常容易携带，而且在你的公司里也非常容易分配，而且它不会生锈。确实。在你的公司里分配，而且它不会生锈，确实，你可以把它带回西班牙，你可以用它来买，你知道，一个不错的农场，不错的庄园，提升你的家庭，这就是黄金的意义，你知道，获取你无法携带的资源是没有意义的，所以这就是为什么人们想要黄金。所以格里哈尔瓦继续这种航行，他发现了另一个岛屿，在那里他比
Hernandez de Cordoba was the first time because he finds tons of altars, tons of skulls, a lot of blood splashed around. And he and his men call this island the Isla de Sacrificios, the Island of Sacrifices. So they're now thinking, you have to get inside the Spaniards' heads. They're excited, they're greedy, they want the money. They genuinely believe in Christians. They want to convert people. But at the same time, there's an element of dread. They're like astronauts landing on an alien planet. It's the final frontier. Yeah, absolutely it is. It is science fiction quality to it.
埃尔南德斯·德·科尔多瓦第一次时感到更加不安，因为他发现了大量的祭坛，大量的头骨，到处溅满了血。他和他的部下把这个岛称为“祭祀岛”。所以他们现在在想，你必须进入西班牙人的头脑。他们很兴奋，他们很贪婪，他们想要钱。他们真诚地相信基督徒。他们想要皈依人们。但与此同时，有一种恐惧感。他们就像降落在外星行星上的宇航员。这是最后的边疆。是的，绝对是。它有科幻小说的品质。
Absolutely it is, Tom. And a lot of science fiction is inspired by these moments, isn't it? Lots of stories of human colonization, of alien worlds, and so on. I mean, this is very much kind of Captain Kirk era Star Trek. Yes, absolutely it is. So good news for Grialva. He looks over to the mainland from this island, and he sees a load of blokes on the beach waving white flags. They eventually go across, the Spaniards, and these people turn out to be the people called the Totonacs. And they are very friendly. We don't know much about the Totonacs. A lot of their history is uncertain. They were very famous. They had very fancy clothes. They had nice sandals and all this
绝对是，汤姆。很多科幻小说都是受这些时刻的启发，不是吗？很多关于人类殖民、外星世界等等的故事。我的意思是，这非常像是柯克船长时代的《星际迷航》。是的，绝对是。所以对格里哈尔瓦来说是个好消息。他从这个岛上望向大陆，看到海滩上有一群家伙挥舞着白旗。他们最终过去了，西班牙人，这些人原来是托托纳克人。他们非常友好。我们对托托纳克人了解不多。他们的很多历史是不确定的。他们非常出名。他们有非常华丽的衣服。他们有漂亮的凉鞋和所有这些
kind of thing. But they were particularly well-known in Mesoamerica for their extraordinary facial decorations. They were great fans of plugs. Do you like a plug? Love a plug. So they would put kind of crystal plugs through their ears and their noses and their lips. Yeah. Now you can imagine for the Spaniards, I mean, it's equally bizarre, of course,
之类的东西。但他们在美索美洲特别出名的是他们非凡的面部装饰。他们是插件的忠实粉丝。你喜欢插件吗？喜欢插件。所以他们会把某种水晶插件穿过他们的耳朵、鼻子和嘴唇。是的。现在你可以想象对西班牙人来说，我的意思是，当然，对托托纳克人看到西班牙人来说，同样是离奇的。
for the Totonacs to see the Spaniards. Yeah, of course. But for the Spaniards, they think these are very surprising looking individuals. It's a long way from Seville. It is a long way. Yeah, you've come a long way now from the tapas bars of Seville. Now the Tottenhacks speak a language the Spanish have not heard before,
是的，当然。但对西班牙人来说，他们认为这些人看起来非常令人惊讶。离塞维利亚很远。确实很远。是的，你现在离塞维利亚的小吃吧很远了。现在托托纳克人说一种西班牙人以前没听过的语言，
which is called Nahuatl. Isn't it Nahuatl? It depends how you pronounce it, Tom. I think it's Nahuatl. As I said, we're a linguistically diverse podcast. So how on earth does Spanish speak to them? I do not know. They probably use Maya interpreters who maybe have a smattering of Nahuatl and perhaps have picked up some Spanish. Anyway, it is the Totonacs who first say to the Spaniards, there's this massive empire in land run by people who push us around and are much richer than we are. And so these are the Mexica, what we would call the Aztecs. They say there's this great city, the city of the Mexica. And there, the Totonacs say, we send them tribute twice a year. We send them cloaks. We send them some of the lovely clothes that we embroider. We send them jewels. We send them feathers. We send them cacao beans and all
叫纳瓦特尔语。不是纳瓦特尔语吗？这取决于你怎么发音，汤姆。我认为是纳瓦特尔语。正如我所说，我们是一个语言多元化的播客。那么西班牙语到底是怎么和他们交流的呢？我不知道。他们可能使用玛雅翻译，他们可能懂一点纳瓦特尔语，也许学了一些西班牙语。无论如何，正是托托纳克人首先对西班牙人说，内陆有一个庞大的帝国，由那些摆布我们且比我们富有得多的人统治。所以这些是墨西加人，我们称之为阿兹特克人。他们说有一个伟大的城市，墨西加人的城市。在那里，托托纳克人说，我们每年向他们进贡两次。我们送他们斗篷。我们送他们一些我们绣的漂亮衣服。我们送他们珠宝。我们送他们羽毛。我们送他们可可豆和所有
this stuff. And these people, say the Totonacs, are really rich and powerful. They live in houses made of stone. They have very strict laws. They have rules. And the Tottenhacks give them a funny detail. They say they gather in public to see justice being done. Of course, what the Tottenhacks are saying is these are people with a regimented state and with a bureaucracy that we don't have. And, you know, a sense of civic order and all this kind of thing, which the Tottenhacks
这些东西。托托纳克人说，这些人真的很富有和强大。他们住在石头做的房子里。他们有非常严格的法律。他们有规则。托托纳克人给了他们一个有趣的细节。他们说他们聚集在公共场合看正义得到伸张。当然，托托纳克人所说的是，这些人拥有一个我们没有的军事化国家和官僚机构。而且，你知道，一种公民秩序感和所有这些东西，托托纳克人
clearly think is extraordinary. But of course, when the Spanish hear this, the Spanish know, oh, this is like a European kingdom. This is a regulated, organized, urban civilization. Or perhaps the emperor of China. Yes. I mean, is there ever any mention of the possibility that this might actually be China or Japan or something? Not actually be China, but I think they're conscious that this is possibly a gateway to China or Japan.
显然认为这是非凡的。但当然，当西班牙人听到这个时，西班牙人知道，哦，这就像一个欧洲王国。这是一个规范的、有组织的、城市化的文明。或者也许是中国的皇帝。是的。我的意思是，有没有提到这实际上可能是中国或日本之类的可能性？不是实际上是中国，但我认为他们意识到这可能是通往中国或日本的门户。
They're still talking about this, by the way. The Columbus dream of getting to Asia is still very much alive and well of getting to Asia. They are still thinking about this as the gateway to Asia. They don't think it is Asia, but they think it's maybe the stepping stone to it. So the Tottenhacks have said this, which is obviously crucial. Then they do something else. They start to bring the Spanish. They say, look at all this lovely stuff we have, gold ornaments, gold tiaras, gold little figures, and all this kind of stuff. And Grialva, you can imagine him. He's been sent by his uncle and he's like,
顺便说一下，他们还在谈论这个。哥伦布到达亚洲的梦想仍然非常活跃，通往亚洲的梦想。他们仍然认为这是通往亚洲的门户。他们不认为它是亚洲，但他们认为它可能是通往亚洲的垫脚石。所以托托纳克人说了这一点，这显然是至关重要的。然后他们做了另一件事。他们开始带西班牙人。他们说，看看我们拥有的所有这些可爱的东西，金饰、金头饰、金小雕像，以及所有这些东西。格里哈尔瓦，你可以想象他。他是被他叔叔派来的，他心想，
brilliant. Whoa, this is it. And he says to their spokesman, their chief, you've got a lot more of this. And the chief, because he's showing off, because he wants to boast about the riches of his people and their land, because he's hospitable, he says, loads, we're rolling in it. I can get gold dust from the hills. He says, my men can bring you a pipe of gold dust as long and thick as a man's finger. He says, our streams run with gold. We can turn it into plates and bars and whatever you like. You just name it. Oh dear. Foolish, my friend. Very, very foolish.
太棒了。哇，就是这个。他对他们的发言人，他们的酋长说，你还有很多这样的东西。而酋长，因为他在炫耀，因为他想吹嘘他的人民和他们的土地的财富，因为他好客，他说，多的是，我们富得流油。我可以从山上得到金粉。他说，我的部下可以给你带来一根像人手指一样长和粗的金粉管。他说，我们的溪流里流淌着黄金。我们可以把它做成盘子、金条，随你喜欢。你尽管说。哦，亲爱的。愚蠢，我的朋友。非常，非常愚蠢。
And of course, Grialba, his eyes are glittering, Tom. And then something else really important happens. Another bloke arrives on the coast. And what's actually happened is, while the Spanish have been messing around, putting in for water, talking to Totonacs and whatnot, rumors of their coming have percolated inland. So at this great city that the Tottenhacks have mentioned, reports have arrived from the coast that there are strangers. They haven't come on canoes. They've come in these strange wooden, people say wooden mountains. Vast structures. Yeah. Vast structures, like huge temples made of wood that float in the water. They wear red cloths or hats on their heads to guard against the sun. Their skins are very white, much whiter than ours. They all have long beards, but their hair only comes down to their ears. Because Dominic, isn't it, there's a possibility that Multisuma has been
当然，格里哈尔瓦，他的眼睛在闪闪发光，汤姆。然后发生了另一件非常重要的事情。另一个家伙到达了海岸。实际上发生的事情是，当西班牙人一直在胡闹，停下来取水，与托托纳克人交谈等等时，他们到来的传言已经渗透到内陆。所以在托托纳克人提到的那个伟大的城市，从海岸传来了报告，说有陌生人。他们不是坐独木舟来的。他们乘坐这些奇怪的木头，人们说是木头山。巨大的结构。是的。巨大的结构，就像漂浮在水面上的巨大的木制神庙。他们戴着红色的布或帽子在头上以防晒。他们的皮肤非常白，比我们白得多。他们都有长胡子，但头发只垂到耳朵。因为多米尼克，不是吗，有一种可能性是蒙特祖马已经
aware of these strange structures appearing along the coast even earlier? Yes. Because they've been going for quite a while. I mean, this is kind of like a president in the White House being alerted to the intrusion of unidentified flying objects off Jupiter or something. Exactly. Exactly. He undoubtedly, the Aztecs undoubtedly, will have heard reports of this. And in fact, the guy who arrives now on the coast has been sent from the city. He is a guy called Teocla Macazqui, and he has a brilliant title, Tom, which I envy.
意识到这些奇怪的结构甚至更早地出现在海岸沿线？是的。因为他们已经走了很长一段时间了。我的意思是，这有点像白宫的总统被警告有不明飞行物闯入木星附近之类的。完全正确。完全正确。他无疑，阿兹特克人无疑会听到关于此的报告。事实上，现在到达海岸的那个家伙是从城市派来的。他是一个叫特奥克拉·马卡兹基的人，他有一个很棒的头衔，汤姆，我很羡慕。
His title is he's the keeper of the house of darkness. That's a great name. Now he arrives from this city that the Spanish have just heard reports of, and he has tons of gifts. He has gold necklaces. He has gold bracelets. He has feathers. He has jewels. He has himself rode out to the Spanish ship, the flagship. He arrives, he speaks the same language as the Totonacs, Nahuatl. And he says, here are these lovely gifts. Here you go. Very nice to meet you. The Spanish are delighted.
他的头衔是“黑暗之屋的守护者”。那是个很棒的名字。现在他从西班牙人刚刚听说报告的那个城市赶来，他带着大量的礼物。他有金项链。他有金手镯。他有羽毛。他有珠宝。他亲自划船到西班牙船，旗舰。他到了，他说了和托托纳克人一样的语言，纳瓦特尔语。他说，这些是可爱的礼物。给你。很高兴见到你。西班牙人很高兴。
They're very hospitable. The girl says, will you have some nice turkey with us? Yeah, lovely. All good. They give him some wine. He loves the wine. He's delighted by the wine. He's never had anything like that before.
他们非常热情。女孩说，你会和我们一起吃点美味的火鸡吗？是的，可爱。一切都好。他们给了他一些酒。他喜欢这种酒。他很高兴喝到酒。他以前从未喝过这样的东西。
The Spanish, they've slightly run out of gifts now. So they give him some bead necklaces and some ship's biscuits, which is kind of a terrible gift. The lesser of two weevils. But he smiles weakly and says, thank you very much. Lovely to meet you. Of course, you're always welcome. And then off he goes.
西班牙人，他们现在礼物有点用完了。所以他们给了他一些珠子项链和一些船用饼干，这是一种糟糕的礼物。两害相权取其轻。但他勉强笑了笑说，非常感谢。很高兴见到你。当然，随时欢迎。然后他就走了。
Now, Grialva is sitting there on his ship and he thinks to himself, this has gone brilliantly. This is so much better than I could have dreamed of. There's a civilization there with cities. They have tons of gold. They all seem very friendly. This is great. So what he doesn't do, Tom, which is absolutely crucial, because otherwise we'd be doing all these podcasts about Juan de Grialva. Yeah.
现在，格里哈尔瓦坐在他的船上，他心想，这太棒了。这比我梦想的要好得多。那里有一个有城市的文明。他们有大量的黄金。他们看起来都很友好。这太棒了。所以他没做的是，汤姆，这绝对是至关重要的，因为否则我们就会一直在做所有关于胡安·德·格里哈尔瓦的播客。是的。
He doesn't go after them to the city because he hasn't been told to. Well, but also, Dominic, I mean, it's not just that. To go herring off into the middle of a country with an enormous great empire and terrifying temples and they've seen all the blood and things. I mean, you'd have to be mad to do that or insanely brave. Or a gambler, Tom. So Grialva doesn't do that. He's only got a couple of hundred men and some dogs and stuff. He's not going to do that. That would, as you say, be mad.
他没有追随他们去城市，因为他没有被告知要这样做。嗯，但还有，多米尼克，我的意思是，不仅仅是那样。冲进一个拥有庞大帝国和可怕神庙的国家，他们已经看到了所有的血和东西。我的意思是，你必须疯了才会那样做，或者极其勇敢。或者是一个赌徒，汤姆。所以格里哈尔瓦没有那样做。他只有几百人和一些狗之类的。他不会那样做。正如你所说，那会是疯狂的。
He thinks, I'll have a little potter up the coast, carry on going, see if there's more stuff. However, in the meantime, he says to one of his lieutenants, a guy who will definitely be featuring a lot in this story, who is a guy called Pedro de Alvarado, who is a swashbuckling, a big, charismatic, flamboyant character. He says to Alvarado, who is a swashbuckling, a big charismatic flamboyant
他心想，我会沿着海岸走一小段，继续走，看看还有没有别的东西。然而，与此同时，他对他的副手之一说，一个肯定会在这个故事中占很大比重的人，一个叫佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多的人，他是一个挥舞着剑的、大人物、有魅力、浮夸的角色。他对阿尔瓦拉多说，他是一个挥舞着剑的、大人物、有魅力、浮夸的
character. He says to Alvarado, right, listen, you go back to Cuba, go to my uncle, show him all the gold, tell him I'm going to carry on and see what's further up the coast, but you go back there now. Alvarado does just that. He dates one of the ships. He goes off back to Cuba. He arrives in Cuba in the early autumn of 1518, an absolutely crucial moment in this. He goes to Santiago, the capital, shown in to see Velazquez, and he says, look at all this. This is what we've seen. And these are the blokes that we've met. This is what's going on. Velazquez is delighted. This is what he dreamed of. So what Velazquez needs is Cuba's all right, but it's not the bee's knees.
角色。他对阿尔瓦拉多说，好吧，听着，你回古巴，去找我叔叔，给他看所有的黄金，告诉他我要继续走，看看海岸上还有什么，但你现在就回去。阿尔瓦拉多正是这样做的。他约会了其中一艘船。他回到了古巴。他在1518年初秋到达古巴，这是其中一个绝对关键的时刻。他去了首都圣地亚哥，被带去见维拉斯奎兹，他说，看看所有这些。这就是我们所看到的。这些就是我们遇到的人。这就是正在发生的事情。维拉斯奎兹很高兴。这就是他梦想的。所以维拉斯奎兹需要的是古巴还可以，但它不是最好的。
If he can get this land with all this gold, so much the better if he can stake his claim. However, he has to move quickly because some other Spanish entrepreneur will get there first. And he's particularly worried about the bloke who is on Hispaniola, the governor of Hispaniola, who is Diego Colon, who is the son of Christopher Columbus. He has to get there before Colon does. Right. And so this is what's going back to your early days of Facebook comparison. Right. Exactly. That you can't afford to let a competitor get a competitive advantage. Exactly. Exactly, Tom. So Velazquez thinks, Grialva's gone up there, I'll send another relative, someone I can rely on. He's got a
如果他能得到这片拥有所有这些黄金的土地，如果他能宣示他的主权，那就更好了。然而，他必须迅速行动，因为其他西班牙企业家会先到那里。他特别担心那个在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛的人，伊斯帕尼奥拉岛的总督，也就是迭戈·科隆，他是克里斯托弗·哥伦布的儿子。他必须在科隆之前到达那里。对。所以这就是回到你早期的Facebook比较。对。完全正确。你不能让竞争对手获得竞争优势。完全正确。完全正确，汤姆。所以维拉斯奎兹心想，格里哈尔瓦已经上去了，我会派另一个亲戚，我可以依赖的人。他有
couple of cousins who've got their big estates in Cuba. He says to them, chaps, do you fancy going on the voyage? And they don't because they think I've already got my estate on Cuba. What do I need to go over there for? You know, it's very risky. But Dominic, is there a man of hunger, aptitude, ability lurking around who seems to be a bit of a loser and who therefore can be kept safely under Velazquez's thumb? That's exactly it, Tom. He doesn't want someone who's too good. He doesn't want somebody who's shown himself to be incredibly swashbuckling and enterprising. He wants somebody who's basically can be pushed around. Somebody who he knows... A functionary.
几个在古巴有大庄园的表亲。他对他们说，伙计们，你们想去航行吗？他们不想，因为他们心想，我已经有我在古巴的庄园了。我为什么要到那边去？你知道，这风险很大。但多米尼克，有没有一个饥饿、有能力、有才华的人潜伏在附近，他似乎有点失败，因此可以安全地被维拉斯奎兹控制？正是这样，汤姆。他不想要一个太好的人。他不想要一个表现得极其挥舞剑、有进取心的人。他想要一个基本上可以被摆布的人。一个他知道……一个功能官。
A functionary. Somebody who's good at form filling. As one of the accounts puts it, he needs a man of much heart, but little spirit. It's the greatest mistake that Velazquez would ever make because the man he picks is, of course, Hernan Cortes. And on that bombshell, I think we should draw a line there, Dominic, under our first episode. I know that you wanted to carry on for much longer, but I think we've really run out of time. But that's fine because we can have as many
一个功能官。一个擅长填表的人。正如其中一份记录所说，他需要一个“有心但没胆”的人。这是维拉斯奎兹所犯的最大错误，因为他挑选的人当然是埃尔南·科尔特斯。在那颗重磅炸弹上，我想我们应该在那里画一条线，多米尼克，在我们的第一集下。我知道你想继续讲更久，但我认为我们真的没时间了。但这没关系，因为我们可以有尽可能多的
episodes as we want and need to tell this story because it truly is, to reiterate, I think this is one of the supreme narratives in the whole of world history and well worth taking time over. So if you want to wait for the subsequent episodes, that's fine. If, however, you are a Spanish conquistador kind of consumer, you don't want to hang around. You want to get out there immediately. You want to get them at once. Then you can do that by joining the Rest Is History Club, where you will find all the episodes in this series waiting for you. So, you know, be a Cortez, go out, get them. And we will see you either in a few minutes or in a few days.
剧集，我们想要和需要讲述这个故事，因为它确实是，重申一下，我认为这是整个世界历史上最伟大的叙事之一，非常值得花时间。所以如果你想等待后续剧集，那没关系。然而，如果你是一个西班牙征服者类型的消费者，你不想徘徊。你想立即出去。你想立刻得到他们。那么你可以通过加入《余谈历史》俱乐部来做到这一点，在那里你会发现这个系列的所有剧集都在等着你。所以，你知道，做一个科尔特斯，走出去，得到他们。我们会在几分钟或几天后见到你。
But either way, hasta luego. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
但无论如何，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。